how are you Raymond hello my little
angel of delight see that's the way to
return in kind after that monstrous
setup that I read verbatim that you
emailed me earlier yeah you know well
you forgot the part about me winning the
Nobel Prize in Chemistry I forgot about
that darn it
well that's email for you so what do you
think of the Jon Gruden regalia that was
rolled out the silver and black carpet
that got rolled out yesterday right well
I was surprised there wasn't more
pandering toward Las Vegas this was more
sort of a classic Oakland press
conference they did it in the in the
weight room at the Coliseum there were
very few frills and not much glitz it
was Jon Gruden selling Jon Gruden and
other than that it was pretty
boilerplate I mean you've got from Jon
Gruden oh what you thought you'd get and
you know he was it was long run
inspirational and short on details but
that's what press conferences are now so
no I thought that was the only thing
that surprised me is that they didn't
pander more to their future audience
well I mean because to me I a shovel has
been put in the ground there right I
mean dirt has been yeah oh no yeah
they're going yeah it's not like they
hired him because they want to change
their mind I know cuz to me it's just
this is honestly the weirdest most
unique relocation I've ever seen where
it where the fans are still all in and
the and the organization is talking
directly to their fans that is soon to
be in the rearview mirror ray I've never
seen anything like it
well they were less all-in as the season
deteriorated you started to hear more
people complaining about well you know
now they're leaving in two years they've
screwed us again but now they're back on
board because the one thing that Mark
Davis has had a real predilection for
throughout his ownership is to reach
back to the past
he hired Reggie Mackenzie because Ron
Wolf who was basically Al Davis's
right-hand man told him that regime'
Kennedy was
the most qualified candidate say I
reject Del Rio because he played his
high school football and basketball in
Hayward and it's still sort of a high
school icon there Marshawn Lynch you
don't even have to explain it you know
and now John Bruton is very much Mark
Davis trying to make up for what I think
many people can consider Al the biggest
mistake so I mean it was another step to
the past which Raider fans like and it's
one of the last chances they'll get to
do that before they pick up space so ray
when did Mark Davis do you think best
you can tell decide that whatever was
going on with Jack Del Rio certainly off
of a terrific season last year that I
think we can all agree could have should
have would have wound up differently had
Derek cars legs stayed intact when do
you think he decided I'm gonna take this
moon shot with Gruden one last time
during the season best you can tell I
would say about midway through I think
the game that probably derailed this
team was early on when they lost to
Washington in such decisive fashion but
I think it was probably about once a
game ten because by then you could see
that the wheels had come off you know
the the offense wasn't functioning
nearly the level it had through to cover
up for that defense the lack of home was
you know Waukee at best and and I think
at that point I I think he made one more
run at Gruden on the theory I don't
think he did it then but I think he did
it
you know as soon as he could I think he
had decided if Cruden doesn't take this
maybe I stay with us one more year but
Gruden was ready to go for any number of
reasons not including the the second
10-year contract in the history of the
National Football League and the third
one's going to be given a Jimmy
Garoppolo by the Niners right ray
Renault correct I think they'll stop
short at eight and then but with a
couple of option years it is amazing how
much life got breathed into the 49 or
franchise the minute he got out there
started playing football in that uniform
well I mean he he did
he did the one thing that 49er fans will
fall for every time he he threw the ball
and got their offense moving I mean
they're I mean even through the best
years of the Harbaugh era it was a
defense first team and I think 49ers
have liked that 49er fans have like that
but they've never loved it and he came
basically well first of all he falls out
of the sky you know I don't think they
they thought that he was going to be
available in fact nobody thought he was
going to be available so basically he's
he's a Christmas present in October and
so now that can be excited about this
because they know that it's that the
future is not brian hoyer or CJ Beathard
now all of a sudden they have a future
at quarterback and then he comes in and
for five straight games he does things
that they like to watch and so now I
mean people are so over their skis about
him that they basically forgotten that
he will be capable of losing games for
you because he he does take chances and
he does throw into tight coverages
sometimes and he's going to break their
hearts from time to time but they have
someone that can hang their hat on in an
era in which finding a good quarterback
is the hardest thing in the world to do
and they didn't have to work very hard
to get there so that's pretty much that
and you know it does set up an
interesting 2018 rate router NBC Sports
Bay Area what do you think going in
right now is the reasonable level of
expectation for that franchise next year
Oh a forty seven nothing win on the
Super Bowl it's a very high bar a
reasonable a reasonable I would say ten
and six that will not that that will be
considered low balling by most 49er fans
because they look at a diminished
division okay in which the only team
that you know looks like it's pointed in
the right direction is is Los Angeles
and they're a Todd Gurley injury away
from being back in the soup again and I
don't think that you know there's there
so dreamy-eyed now I think they're
they're they're men
making those transformations to that 81
clue that ended up like 13 and three and
one at all after winning two games in 79
and six and 80 I think some people
already staking out that territory I
think the more sensible numbers 10 ray
Ratto NBC Sports Bay Area here on the
Rich Eisen show the NBA season to me has
just a handful of major storylines that
coming in we were gonna come cover it
come heck or high water reward obviously
being one LeBron and Paul George's
whereabouts another what's going on with
the Celtics being another one that is
seemingly come up out of nowhere has
been the relationship between the
referees and the players and it seems
that draymond Green Kevin Durant and the
Warriors are right there in the middle
of it would you say that's a fair
assessment of what's going on in the NBA
Ray Ratto
III think I think it well nothing on
radio is a fair assessment of anything
we're on TV - right so okay well in that
case oh it's absolutely legitimate I
think the Warriors you know one of the
things that one of the chips they were
on their shoulders is the sense that
they don't get superstar respect from
officials that they don't get treated
with the same you know deference on
calls that LeBron James does or that
Kobe Bryant did and one I would dispute
that because the way they play you know
when you're shooting from the outside
you're not going to get as many foul
calls you know I mean I think they they
think that you know in a way they're not
getting their due from the officials
because basically nearly every call one
of the wars is is incredibly aggrieved
you know Andre Iguodala both as harm
arms out more than touchdown Jesus but I
think the bigger problem and the one
that draymond Green is in the middle of
is that officials don't want to talk to
players anymore I think in part because
fewer
fewer players know how to talk to
officials it's a dying art that
seemingly nobody wants to teach the next
generation so now when a player wants to
say something to a referee
it's an agonized why do you suck and you
know no no self-respecting adults going
to answer that one so I think it's a
combination of the league is trying to
be more inflexible in a business it
requires nothing but flexibility and
secondly that the players are not doing
the due diligence that their forebears
did in terms of working officials
knowing how you can talk to separate
different guys I mean because they are
different people and you know the bigger
the biggest problem now quite frankly is
the number of retirements of top quality
guys I mean Marty McCutchen retired this
year he was considered the best there
was at the beginning of the year Danny
Crawford who was the best guy at talking
with players he retired Joey Crawford
retired a year ago because his knee went
out and they're not being replaced by
sort of flexible chatting you know guys
who can actually sort of navigate a game
so that everybody feels like they got a
fair shot so I think part of it is
structural in the way the league wants
officials to be and part of it is
players don't know how to talk to
officials and I imagine the officials
who are still there won't take too
kindly when they read draymond greens
theory that we should just start from
scratch wipe them all out and get some
new guys in here
well draymond Green is a really smart
guy who's had a really stupid thing and
not because the officials will take it
out on him although some might it's the
notion that if you fire the 70 people
you have that you're gonna find 70
people who are better than those it
doesn't work that way you're getting
number 71 through 140 and if you don't
like the the best 70 you're sure as hell
doesn't like 71 through 140 and that's
you know that's a simple math I mean
when they went to three officials they
didn't get you know 25 people who were
better than the ones that I had they got
25 people or worse which made the
officiating worse and from that moment
on the NBA has tried to figure out a way
to stander
officiating to the point where it can no
longer endure
you know the replay rules are absurd
every time a league office tries to
meddle in officiating beyond its
competence it ends up badly the National
Football League is as classic an example
this is an it I mean you don't know what
anything is anymore I mean everything
it's a you know it's a rolling crapshoot
depending on who's holding the rulebook
upside down when they're reading it from
3,000 miles away I mean if you if you
cannot tell your your viewers what a
catch is you have a fundamental problem
with what you're doing and that's not
just a catch that's fashion appearance
that's false start that's a basement I
mean the NFL and I going off on a
tangent here but they don't know how to
present football anymore that's an issue
and the end and the NBA by trying to
standardize this and make it a more
inflexible place where you can't talk to
a guy that's going to be a problem to
and Adam silver needs to jump on that
quickly before it gets worse
Raymond I always love chatting with you
just one last thing for you to keep in
your schedule potentially and I don't
like taking gigs away from Andrew
Siciliano who is one of my colleagues he
sits in on the show on occasion normally
he is the one who emcees this thing but
I don't know if you noticed there is
going to be a coin flip between the
Raiders and the 49ers at the combine is
to see who drafts ninth in the NFL Draft
and who drafts tenth I think you would
be the perfect emcee to flip that coin
ray and be the guide to break the news
to certain members of the Bay Area that
they're drafting ninth and drafting
tenth I think you'd be perfect well as
long as we can do it my way which is to
take the coin throat as far away as it
gets and then have Jon Gruden and Kyle
Shanahan run for it and then fight til
somebody like the XFL like the XFL annoy
explosives quality you need body parts
flying in the air that's just that's
just a rule of mine
nobody can spit ball like you were a rat
oh thanks for joining appreciate it
bye honey that's NBC Sports Bay air
israei righto here in the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience